the NFL is placing a big bet on the
country's most famous gambling mecca a
headline in this morning San Francisco
Chronicle reads this Raiders off to
Vegas the league yesterday approved a
request by the Raiders to leave Oakland
and relocate to Las Vegas Nevada the
move is expected in two to three years
that's how long it's going to take to
build a new stadium shown in this
rendering Mireya Villarreal is at
Caesars Palace that's on the Las Vegas
Strip with how the league put aside past
concerns but a a good morning good
morning the image of this city has
changed over the decades and apparently
that's part of the reason why the NFL
approved the move the city's formerly
seedy reputation has shifted and now the
city is known as a big leak
entertainment capital hopefully ready
for a big league football team it's been
a long time coming for these Las Vegas
sports fans the city is finally home to
an NFL franchise the point is Vegas is
the best thing for the Raiders NFL
Commissioner Roger Goodell agrees it's
an important step in trying to get
stability for the for the Raiders long
term like many things in Las Vegas a big
factor is money to lure the team away
from Oakland Vegas offered seven hundred
and fifty million dollars courtesy of a
visitor's tax while Bank of America has
put up a six hundred and fifty million
dollar loan but perhaps the biggest
incentive a new 65,000 seat domed
stadium still Raiders owner Mark Davis
says the decision wasn't easy I love the
fans in Oakland and I know that there's
going to be disappointment and maybe
some anger these Oakland Raider fans
will have their loyalties tested over
the next two years the team will still
be playing in Northern California while
the new Las Vegas stadium is being built
there are fans in Oakland who will
relish the opportunity to continue to
support the team in its last year's in
Oakland there will be fans who say no
thank you
but the phrase no thank you is familiar
to Vegas sports fans both the Utah Jazz
and Oakland Athletics had reportedly
considered moving to Vegas but decided
no many were apparently concerned about
put
athletes in a city where gamblers could
try to influence the game I think the
perception of that was perhaps there was
something untoward or unseemly about it
the aversion to Vegas I believe was
antiquated and clearly the league has
agreed with that the question is now
whether other major teams will roll the
dice and follow the lead of the Oakland
Raiders or the city's new Hockey League
franchise the Vegas Golden Knights as we
all know the odds for success here in
Vegas are good but there is no sure bet
Noora
that's right Mariah may call in Las
Vegas for a reason yeah what's it gonna
be like though for the Oakland fans
after cheer for a team that they know is
leaving but you know this team has left
Oakland before before and went to Los
Angeles I don't think they're gonna be
very happy in Oakland for the next
couple years we'll see we'll see we'll
see anybody